moschitz und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge der hacker show und
bevor wir mit der folge diese woche
beginnen ja ich weiß sie kommt am
dienstag die letzten sonntag mit meiner
familie unterwegs deswegen konnte sich
bringen und heute muss sie auch noch mal
ohne max kommen bei max gerade für
seinen mathe abitur lernt und gar nicht
zurecht kommt und keine zeit findet zum
aufnehmen deswegen oder solo zwei dinge
möchte ich vorhersagen vorbei loslegen
und zwar zuallererst ich habe letztens
wieder wind davon bekommen dass es
wirklich noch leute gibt die heck
clients verkaufen
leute ich bitte euch wirklich geht nicht
geld für so einen scheiß ausgibt bitte
nicht geld dafür aus dass ihr in den
blog spiel für das sie sowieso schon
geld bezahlt habt noch schummeln dürfte
es macht einfach keinen sinn macht so
was nicht ist es aber unnötig und
zweitens es scheint ja wirklich einige
orte zu geben die sich cool führen weil
sie in minecraft hacken sei im mai kommt
es eigentlich ein spiel was vielleicht
für das älteste publikum ausgelegt ist
ja trotzdem ist bis heute die in diesem
spiel
schummeln ja und dann sie ernsthaft da
so der mast was drauf einbilden wo ich
mich frage was ist mit der menschheit
los wie sehr können die leute an der
realität vorbei schlittern dass sie
denken dass sie so etwas gemacht ich
weiß nicht ich fühle mich auf diesem
planeten nicht mehr wohl und ich werde
mir auch in naher zukunft auf jeden fall
dass neben ihrer ok damit haben wir das
schon mal geklärt und ling los mit der
ersten sendung der ssk helga show meint
black sheep quest und stammt von
kubitschek albert hirsch am wasser am
status mein blacks wie wir da sehen und
beim schaf skicross
ich habe auch keine ahnung ich ganz
ehrlich für mich wieso ein opa ich habe
mittlerweile keine ahnung davon welche
spielmodi was was ist skicross weiß was
irgend einer von euch was schief quest
ist gibt es da draußen irgendeinen
menschen der jemals von diesem
spielmodus gehört hat solltet ihr zu
dieser seltenen minderheit gehören dann
schreibe es in die kommentare und
erhaltet eine büroklammer als belohnung
ich weiß ja nicht an meine arab sensoren
tingeln leute meinen arm sind dass die
ab sensoren die hat glaube ich jeder
mensch irgendwann kopf gucken wir hier
drauf wer noch von hinten an den typen
raña kriegt einfach inseln schläge und
das andere sich umdreht so ries
morys morys berichtet ich schwör's
hätten ihm anruft hast du so was darf
einmal dreht ob
naja okay dann muss man nur von hinten
den typen reinlaufen hinzubekommen alles
klar
und bevor jetzt schon platz fünf die
absolute oberhauses krieg schreiben
weiter zu platz 4 und gucken was da so
abgeht
ok platz vier heißt es kate kann auf ich
hab noch gar nicht darauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass ihr eure hashtags
bereithalten soll deswegen an dieser
stelle alle hashtags bereiten machen
klar machen zur benutzung android scan
usg und john sks 4 stammt von katze maz
abseits der ball der junge bauer hat
smart der flyer der gut bevor wir
loslegen leute herzens hat das ding zwar
nicht auf einer kartoffel aufgenommen
aber wohl in einem kartoffel format
eingeschickt ist es nicht 16 zu 9
bitte bitte bitte wenn ihr was einsendet
achtet darauf 16 09 muss sein
wir packen das na ja wir sind zehn
sekunden im video und haben und bürgen
typen da oben
what the [ __ ]
also ist natürlich immer wieder durch
die gegend schüttet also ich bin mir
auch nicht hundertprozentig sicher leute
aber ich glaube nicht dass das der sinn
eines monitors ist dass man einfach wie
eine geistesgestörte ufo war durch die
gegend schießen der luft ok jetzt wieder
hin schon mal angreifen es deckt sich
hoch bei null steuern
leute was was hat jetzt in diesem moment
eigentlich vor offensichtlicher weise
wie diese andere typ die ganze runde
lang nicht kämpfen sondern einfach nur
alleine da oben rumfliegen horizont auch
an natürlich auch noch 1 petek und pro
tag älter er trifft mit dem vorfall oder
warm wie eine gesenkte sauer raster über
die ganze map wir beenden einsendung 4
mit der preisverleihung für das
seltsamste move mit den minecraft im
jahr 2016
das geht an diesen typen darf
ok platz drei ist merkwürdige sg hacker
auf den zeitpunkt tv und stammt von
laptop ich hab mich gerade von den
strapazen zu platz vier und fünf ein
bisschen erholt wieder einsatzbereit und
wir legen los also re winterpunkt tv und
sg alles klar
leider vergisst aber wenn man die treppe
hochgeht
es bisschen zu schnell eigentlich es
bisschen schneller als er eigentlich
sein sollte es aber sehr zielstrebig
muss man sagen okay alter was geht jetzt
ab hat es gesehen wie auf einmal sind ja
genau
ja ja ja ja das ist viel zu schnell man
komm mal runter
wir schauen jetzt mal diese stelle anja
erlaubt durch die gegend und achte jetzt
mal auf seine bewegung wenn er sich dem
gegner nähert und auf einmal dritter
durch bam bam bam bam bam bam spam des
todes ist übel schnell ich sag ich sagte
typ wahrscheinlichen fake bot so wie
siehst du selbst anbieter sich verhält
wenn er von gegnern einfach fk hat die
leertaste eingeklemmt er springt die
ganze zeit passt eigentlich springt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die landeseigene
kempf mal angemacht und ok jetzt noch
eingefunden denkt aber auch irgendwie
der treppe geklebt hat es scheint ein
ding heutzutage auf gewinnseite auf den
treppen zu kleben wusste ich persönlich
jetzt auch noch nicht immer ich bin ja
auch schon vom alten eisen
damit endet unsere einsätze mit einem
angeles kate ist dazu möchte ich kurz
das sagen leute ich finds mega mega mega
cool wie dieses enjoy skating
mittlerweile die runde macht mich so
gefühlt jeder in jede einsendung
verwendet das freut mich echt immer zu
sehen aber das war sehr sehr seltsame
bewegung sehr seltsam bewegung aber
wieder einiges dazu gelernt und wir
springen zu platz zwei platz 2 heißt
hacker überlebt sprung aus über 100
blöcken höhe hashtag angeles casetech
und jetzt wird's spannend acker senf
beziehungsweise in klammern hacker senf
wieder am start und das ist der
spannende teil das video kommt wieder
von wieder reports und die ist ja auch
schon fähigkeit urgestein audi auch
schon öfters mal dabei wieder die
reporta sie hat dass hier ein geschickt
und es ist wieder hacker seien vom staat
ganz ehrlich so langsam zweifel glaube
ich der letzte daran dass mit dem alles
mit rechten dingen zugeht der ist immer
dabei wenn hacker am start sind und
momentan auf jeden fall auch konformen
ebenfalls auf jeden fall die chance darf
man alles glastec ist der gehsteig i in
the sky okay okay das läuft nichts mit
dem springen und jetzt pass auf
seht ihr dass da in der luft team das
ist ratet mal richtig hacker senf oder
acker sind wie manche nennen die noch
nicht seine wahre identität kennen und
er ist schon wieder da und schon wieder
ist offensichtlich dass der typ act aber
ist und nicht gebannt ganz ehrlich wenn
es schon so viel beweismaterial dafür
dass er mit den hacker unter einer decke
steckt können wir noch kurz die
bestätigung haben dass es sich um ihn
handelt
so und es im stadtlohner blog aber auf
die marke jetzt da alles klappt er fällt
aus locker 60 70 80 blöcken runter und
stirbt nicht
placed kein korb web und wir sehen auch
für alle die dachten wir das doch wasser
das ist kein wasser das blaue wolle
sieht man auch daran dass er zweifel
drinstecken
und genau hier es ist sehr komisch
es ist sehr komisch da er baut den block
vom hacker senf ab hier zack da fällt
darunter und dann springt er selbst
runter und hacker sind wird daher und er
überlebte den sturz
da sieht man erstmal confirmed hier
rechts da sieht man den namen akasaka
sein hacker senf enjoy hacker cent
weiter wisst ihr was leute ich packe
meine umfrage die beschreibung
beschreibung der erste regen ist eine
umfrage und könnt ihr abstimmen ob er
denkt dass hacker senf ein illuminati
ist und mit den hacker unter einer decke
steckt oder nicht link dazu einer
beschreibung wir müssen eine
entscheidung treffen
herr staeck make komme teenagern und für
alle ließen verstand name ist es
natürlich ein schock aber stimmt
trotzdem ab okay leute platz eins heißt
dass es in jazz kenner 1.9.2 am 1.9
vielleicht ein hacker am start
vielleicht vielleicht hab ich den klub
schon mal gesehen und vielleicht
passieren richtig abgefuckt der dinge da
drin so oder so stammt die einsendung
von land los und wir gucken was da
passiert
hat sich das ding gerade bewegt ich
glaube dass dinge herum hat sich bewegt
kann das sein
ok also ja doch er sagt auch das sei
jemand mit dem boot rom geflogen
ich glaube das ist so ein ding jetzt in
der alten anders sollte ins chaos mit
boden fliegen aber sie müssen selbst mal
an alles klar
enjoy enjoy was wie verstehe nicht ganz
was soll hier ein jetpack von comair
gibt er die vorlage gibt die vorlage
jetzt finish bitte ja was das ding ich
heute anders fogh interesse alles klappt
können wir unbedingt den typen bieten
doch mal sehen mit seinem boot und o ist
vom alles polanski hat jukic haiti
fliegen gebot kommt lola displays es ist
so fucking random leute leute
tatsächlich kürzer tipp offenbart und es
wird was ist das leben überhaupt noch
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt jetzt erwischt
sind in apolda ist komplett neues images
runter runter junge entertainer perle in
der luft kommen abschied alles klar
und da ist wieder das gegengebot das
kommt sowohl natürlich und er gewinnt
das team und der punkte größten brände -
war als er hier meldet er ist kurz
vorzustellen erkämpfte dem tod und da
kommt ein fucking bot angeflogen und
schaut dabei zu
was zur hölle und hängt in der luft dass
das ist die 1.9 leute die zukunft von
minecraft applaus haben dass die zukunft
von minecraft das was weit von der folge
dieser woche der hacker shop wie gesagt
bitte bitte bitte tut mir und euch in
eurem taschengeld und euren eltern vor
allen die die kohle verdienen
wahrscheinlichen gefallen und kauft
keine heck kleines dankeschön dafür und
ansonsten sollte sich früh fühlen sollen
weil sie hacken ist eigentlich auch klar
es klingt auch selbstverständlich aber
die leute graphens teilweise nicht
wirklich sind glücklich heute geheilt
dann irgendwie komische schnörkeln im
youtube namen welche blüten und sind der
festen überzeugung dass die sechs sind
weil sie in minecraft hacken so hat er
macht's gut
cho